do you still like
for exercise purposes or just for fun do
you still ever hoop
I haven't played ball in a while I'm not
gonna lie to you you know I'm I keep it
real like all the time I tell people
I really played basketball like I see a
lot of rappers now I feel like they got
rich and famous and successful right and
now it's like a it's a hobby or a free
time thing and like I played like Drake
like when everybody was there's a
[__] Arena at his house so it's like
Kudos big shouts to Drizzy that's you
know that's that's a [__] from the hood
dream to have a [__] no Jimmy your
crib he was like his own League at his
house you know what I'm saying like I I
wouldn't know how to get [__] out my
house if I had that they'd be spending
the night in the gym but I already know
the Vibes at the end of the day it's
like
with boy I really did that bro from from
from four or five years old to
I got locked up to 21 right like
non-stop I wasn't trying to rap I wasn't
did you do AAU or was that a thing
everything everything that came with AAU
I did all that uh summer league summer
tournament everything like that was my
life until
it wasn't my life right you know what
I'm saying but I always had a love for
rap like I've said so many times like
you know what I mean but that was like I
can remember playing ball and watching
Meek Mill freestyle and when Mick was
getting this [__] together in Philly and
he was doing all them freestyles and I
remember that but I was hooping right
you know what I'm saying mooc shouts the
murder move Loaded Lux all of them like
from Harlem they was inspiring me with
the smack and during the whole Smack DVD
right Great era crazy era but I was
playing basketball so you were you were
like I wasn't I was a fan of that [__] I
wasn't rapping so for me to jump in the
game when I did
after they eat and kind of laid the
blueprint or they've been in it so long
and still get the recognition I got you
know what I'm saying that I'm getting
it's a blessing 100 man
um for you
uh this album you have some West Coast I
mean you've always been super tapped in
in La for like I love Cali you know that
not I feel it's like it's definitely
your second home you know that and
you've been embraced by California
heavily from day one you got tiger and
uh young Gerald on the uh see riddle and
G-Eazy and you know what's crazy about
this album like I didn't I've said this
to the homies but everybody delivered
bro every feature it's gonna be better
you're Dave East but but still but you
know sometimes they'll just be like all
right people just give you a verse
like if if it's like you sending this on
like damn now I gotta come with me you
know I'm gonna talk I'm talking so at
the end of the day you don't want to
just get burnt on the record but at the
same time it's almost like
them is part like the tiger record and
the G-Eazy record ain't really no
lyrical
type of joints like we just those are
kind of more fun right you know what I
mean like but they delivered if you put
a big shout out you put tiger on like a
random Alchemist beat I'd be just gonna
talk I'd be disappointed but but nobody
I don't feel like that's what you want
to hear like I don't think when I heard
the beat actually you know what I do
want to hear that me too I want to hear
Tyga and Alchemist do five songs EP
challenge to the outcome tiger can rap
bro I feel like people don't understand
that he came up under Lil Wayne I don't
know one of the one of the greatest
Weezy one of the greatest bro you don't
think I can rap
I mean he can rap like like rap oh but
you're just so used to hearing him on
certain type of [__] you know what he
had a song his first album he had a song
on his album
like really can spit and I'm a [__]
that really judge people that rap I
don't know so his first album the one
that rack city on it he did have a song
with Big Sean and a song with Nas and he
kept up with them on both records for
sure bro I'll say that but but this is
what I learned
is that me oh that's my Android what's
called my Android [__] you [__] jumping
man hotline man that's like my old old
number I learned this in this game bro
you got to go with what what the people
love him and I'm saying a lot of times
and you gotta go with
was feeding your family you got to go
what's what's what's making in life how
you want it to be so if this is winning
that's why I love like I'm gonna do
what's winning 100 I salute them Tyler
got to do that [__] all day same thing
when like when Flo Rida was like kind of
like came in with po boy and then he
caught a wave and Flo Rida's like I'ma
just do pop records and I'm like bro I
ain't mad at you and look what he look
how he ran it up he just bought Celsius
I know he sued Celsius for like 40
million dollars he ran it big shot out
the Flo Rida he ran it the [__] ran it
up I'm a fan of [__] running the [__]
up like 100 I'm a fan of that